solo una start up per questo vuol dire
che ho creato da poco la mia azienda
la mia per tacco di motion che ha creato
in poco tempo un network internazionale
di 30.000 developer diventando la
conferenza tecnica più grande in italia
spagna e germania
e tutto questo con dietro un film tutto
al femminile 100 per cento donne in un
settore che purtroppo è 90 per cento
uomini
quello che vorrei raccontarvi oggi è la
mia storia dalla passione per
l'informatica e la tecnologia alla
startup code motion mi sono diplomata al
liceo scientifico in classe eravamo 23 e
solo sette ragazze all'università alla
facoltà di ingegneria informatica la
situazione è nettamente peggiorata
eravamo solo 5 ma questa volta su 250 se
vi chiedessi di per scrivermi la vostra
idea di ingegnere informatico
probabilmente mi risponderete maschio e
magari anche un po nerd per scherzarci
sopra un qualcosa del genere
e devo dire che i miei amici
dell'università non erano tanto diversi
da così dopo la laurea
sognavo di diventare una donna in
carriera nella consulenza it ispirandomi
a modelli come la marissa mayer di oggi
i miei amici invece sognavano di
diventare degli hacker del futuro e
river tenevano il lavoro dei miei sogni
come il male assoluto per la categoria
degli sviluppatori
le differenze con loro non erano
soltanto negli obiettivi sul futuro ma
anche nella vita di tutti i giorni
avete mai provato a invitare in
discoteca un gruppo di studenti di
ingegneri informatici
se avete mai trovato ok non lo fate io
ci ho provato varie volte e alla fine mi
ritrovavo qui allora questa on lan party
cioè una cosa veramente molto nerd pizza
birra computer e videogiochi per tutta
la notte
facevo di tutto per cercare di essere
come loro quindi alla fine
i miei divertimenti per seguire loro
addirittura iniziare a giocare al
fantacalcio e quindi ho smesso di
comprare vanity fair a favore della
gazzetta dello sport e minchio d'avola
domenica davanti alle partite
questo perché sentivo proprio questa
necessità di somigliare a loro visto che
praticamente all'università era l'unica
ci siamo laureati molto in fretta
l'essere stati un team affiatato ci ha
aiutato a ottenere degli ottimi
risultati e mi è rimasto però sempre
dentro questo contrasto tra l'essere me
stessa il voler essere come loro
dopo la laurea ho iniziato subito a
lavorare come programmatrice in una
società e ti e anche lì ero l'unica
donna del team così si è aperto un nuovo
periodo di lan party notturni e partita
a calcetto perché questa volta ho anche
cercato di imparare a giocare a calcetto
organizzando partite con mogli fidanzate
dei miei colleghi e questo proprio era
proprio forte questo tentativo di
diventare come loro
dopo un anno che lavoravo in questa
azienda avevo 25 anni mi mandano per la
prima volta da sola a una grande
riunione importante la prima riunione da
un nuovo cliente
me lo ricordo devo dire molto molto bene
arrivo in questa azienda una stanza
abbastanza buia con un enorme tavolo di
noce e un gruppo di grandi capi un po
vecchio stile erano circa sei persone
chi lavorava al computer chi parlava o
parlavano tra loro arrivo io dico il mio
nome è vero che però mi ignorano
dopo un po chiedo perché non iniziamo la
riunione mi guardano e fa non è perché
aspettiamo l'ingegnere a quel punto mi
si gela proprio il sangue e inizia a
chiedermi cosa avrebbero fatto i miei
colleghi al posto mio come risolvere la
situazione cosa cosa dovevo fare
e poi mi è scattata una molla dentro ha
detto no ce la devo fare sono io li devo
smettere di pensare a cosa farebbero
loro al mio posto
devo essere me stessa e così ho
timidamente risposto veramente
l'ingegnere sono io
loro mi hanno guardato con delle facce
come se avessero visto un fantasma e
dopo di che però ha rotto il ghiaccio
scherzando io per primo sul fatto che
probabilmente si aspettavano
uomo magari una persona più grande di me
è quasi poi sono andata avanti con
aneddoti sulla mia vita lavorativa in un
mondo quasi sempre al maschile e ho
portato avanti la riunione
dimostrandogli che ero davvero io
l'ingegnere lì ho capito che dovevo
essere me stessa che non dovevo cercare
di assomigliare ai miei amici maschi ma
dovevo essere felice di essere una donna
in questo settore
la mia vita è cambiata a settembre del
2009 per caso
per me non è stata una m presa o persa
bensì un pranzo all'università
acquistavo per non andare
avevamo organizzato di andare a trovare
i professori e così mi trovo nella
stanza del professor merialdo quando
mara che è seduta qua con noi
la ragazza che organizzava il javaday da
tre anni comunicava che probabilmente
non l'avrebbe più organizzato perché non
ce la faceva da sola il giovane è una
conferenza tecnica per sviluppatori per
ingegneri informatici dedicato alla
tecnologia java i miei amici e il
professore mi guardano si girano tutti
verso di me e mi dicono perché non lo
aiuti tu io ho detto pensare ai trovi
contro il contro era evidente lavoravo
già fino alle 10 di sera ero pieno di
impegni però il proverà ancora più forte
mi appassionava tantissimo l'idea di
poter organizzare gli eventi era una
specie di sogno in più mi piaceva stare
in mezzo alla gente conoscere nuove
persone e quasi alla fine in tre secondi
ho detto sì ho conosciuto mara lei
psicologa che nei ritagli di tempo
studiava programmazione perché non
vedeva l'ora di scrivere le sue prime
righe di codice java io invece come
sapete ingegnere informatico che di
notte studiavo comunicazione abbiamo
creato un team che funzionava proprio
grazie alle nostre nordi differenze e
quasi abbiamo iniziato a lavorare
tantissimo lavorando notti weekend al
nostro evento il giovane per cercare di
farlo crescere
sì diciamo che questo era un po la
situazione molto spesso visto che notte
weekend e non bastavano mai abbiamo
cercato di far crescere i nostri eventi
e giovani
possibile e poi l'abbiamo aperta a tutti
i linguaggi e le tecnologie creando così
code motion un momento di confronto su
tutte le tecnologie quando l'evento ha
raggiunto i 3 mila partecipanti ci siamo
rese conto che le note weekend non
bastavano più e così abbiamo iniziato a
pensare di fare la nostra start up
volete sapere come hanno reagito amici e
parenti enormi risate enormi perplessità
lasci il posto fisso in un periodo come
questo
e poi la peggiore è stata quella del mio
capo che mi ha risposto sai un ingegnere
ti metti organizzare eventi e invece sì
quella era la mia passione quello che mi
piaceva fare poi podemos non è un evento
qualsiasi elemento che crea valore che
crea innovazione e tecnologia e quindi
non mi sono lasciata scoraggiare e a
gennaio ho lasciato il posto fisso e ho
scommesso sulla star tacco the motion
con mara e abbiamo aperto la nostra
nostra azienda
in quest'ultimo anno abbiamo lavorato
tantissimo per farla crescere il più
possibile e devo dire che in parte ci
siamo anche riusciti e ora quote motion
ecco mi dicevo all'inizio una delle più
importanti conferenze tecniche in europa
e si distingue dalle altre grazie ai
contenuti di valore al fatto che
costruiamo il programma dal basso con
l'aiuto di tutte le community riceviamo
oltre 300 proposte di tolte da tutto il
mondo da speaker internazionali ormai
veramente da tutte le parti del mondo e
li selezioniamo con l'aiuto di tutte le
community di developer e quindi il
programma è quello che è veramente i
partecipanti vorrebbero sentire il
network di developer di start up di
aziende di speaker con i mostri è
un'opportunità unica di confronto
condivisione e approfondimento su temi
legati alla tecnologia e poi soprattutto
l'entusiasmo l'entusiasmo che si respira
nei nostri eventi da quando abbiamo
iniziato con motion non è più solo roma
ma è anche milano venezia ma soprattutto
madrid e berlino quindi è una conferenza
italiana che sta avendo successo anche
all'estero e stiamo anche andando alla
scoperta di nuovi territori scoperta
barra conquista tra virgolette dove
contiamo di arrivare nel 2014 in
particolare tel aviv istanbul e varsavia
quando abbiamo deciso di fare la startup
eravamo stanche di fare notti e weekend
lavorando a codemotion in realtà non è
cambiato assolutamente niente nel senso
che continua a lavorare tutte le notti
tutti i week end per ora lo faccio solo
su coremotion sono molto fortunata
perché devo dire che il mio marito tutto
sommato reagisce abbastanza bene questa
cosa
questo è mio marito mi sono sposata
quest'anno il tema alla società ho
deciso anche che era il momento giusto
di sposarmi e devo dire che sto cercando
di trovare e lui in questo mi supporta
un equilibrio difficile tra la vita di
una start up e la vita familiare perché
ci tengo tantissimo
oltre ad essere cresciuti come
conferenze abbiamo attivato anche
numerosi progetti
il progetto che ci tengo tanto a
raccontarvi e il progetto code monkeys
che è un progetto rivolto ai bambini
insegniamo la tecnologia e la
programmazione ai bambini dai 5 ai 12
anni
questo perché crediamo che ormai
programmare sia importante come saper
leggere e scrivere e devo dire che è
entusiasmante vedere nella classe gruppi
di bambini lavorare in team a
programmare a realizzare il loro video
gioco e non a giocare e l'altra cosa che
è veramente entusiasmante che ad esempio
sabato scorso abbiamo abbiamo una
lezione nell'aula saranno circa 32
bambini e quasi il 50 per cento erano
bambine e questa cosa per me è
importantissimo perché siamo convinti
che possa essere un mezzo per aumentare
il numero di donne nel settore della
tecnologia
devo dire che probabilmente non saremmo
mai arrivati fino qua da sole e mare a
tutto questo lo dobbiamo al nostro team
che ci sta credendo tantissimo con noi e
che condivide con noi la nostra vitamina
d
passione entusiasmo e determinazione
la scorsa settimana la mia nipotina di 4
anni george mi ha chiesto che cosa
facevo di lavoro zia cosa fargli lavoro
e mi sono trovato a spiegare una bambina
di 4 anni code motion
così l'ha raccontato così gli ho detto
organizzo delle feste per appassionati
di tecnologia per quelli che lavorano
con l'aipa dell'iphone con cui tu giochi
sempre lei mi ha guardato un po
perplessa detto ma quindi se voglio
essere come te da grande devo imparare
organizzare delle feste e io le ho detto
no devi capire cosa ti piace fare devi
capirlo davvero e cercare di farlo con
passione con entusiasmo e credendoci e
questo spero si sia capito dalla mia
storia perché è quello che ho imparato
in questi anni grazie